the question becomes
who does better with money the the free
market enterprise or the government and
if it's legal and i know that answer we
know the answer to the question but you
and i also know that we got to give a
little bit to the government to get
military to get some of the work that
they do if if you had you know the tax
code very well if you had a structure
for tax code that would benefit and
change the gap middle income upper class
the wealthy how would you change the tax
code
well i think i i i believe in the
progressive income next structure i
think we just got to get rid of more of
the loopholes as i said you know 1031
enables all these real estate
entrepreneurs to roll forward and
definitely capital gains get rid of that
let them pay their taxes in my industry
there's this carried interest thing it's
really ordinary income get rid of that
and you know schumer
talks about taxing the wealthy people
he's a new yorker my guess is he's been
responsible for that legislation not
happening exactly
a lot of real estate people
uh live in new york and a lot of the
private equity people operate in new
york we gotta operate with more
enlightened interest rather than
enlightened self-interest if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you